в ефірі Сергій шкарлуп Міністр освіти і
науки України пане Сергію Вітаю Доброго
дня Слава Україні Героям слава Отож в
освітян почалися уже такі робочі будні і
ті хто навіть не почав першого вересня
освітній процес уже з цього понеділка То
точно приступили до роботи Можете і
зараз сказати скільки шкіл почали
навчання очно за вашу інформацію а
скільки залишилось на дистанційній формі
Дуже дякую пане Володимире канали ICTV
за велику увагу до освітян вже адже
сьогодні освітній фронт не менш важливий
ніж всі інші
розпочну з деяких цифр в нас на сьогодні
12 000 шкіл які в цілому можуть
Приступити до навчання з них
3539 шкіл почали навчання в
повноформатному традиційному режимі На
жаль
5497 шкіл працюють в форматі онлайн і
387 шкіл почали в змішаному форматі в
цілому десь 70 74 батьків в будь-якому
випадку розпочали освітній процес в
школах в змішаному або дистанційному
форматі на 15 вересня Ми розраховуємо на
те що ми приблизно 10,5 тисяч кіл
виведемо на повнуформатний навчання
Враховуючи те що працює все одно триває
робота з проблисковими триває робота з
безпековими умовами триває робота з
батьками і Сьогодні на жаль на жаль
велика така сумна статистика
1288 шкіл знаходиться під окупацією
тобто чи правильно Я розумію що якщо
робота з обладнанням бомбосховищ триває
то є шанси що більша кількість шкіл з
часом за кілька місяців перейдуть на
звичну форму навчання
якщо ми на липень місяць мали лише 11%
шкіл які були атестовані як безпечні
школи ДСНС і комісіями то вже на
сьогодні ми маємо 64% на 15 вересня ми
розраховуємо що такий був буде шкіл
більше 70% і по мірі готовності
богослужінь по мірі готовності
безпекової ситуації школи будуть мати
принаймні не
необхідні умови виходу на онлайн на
офлайн Вибачте навчання
а як у школах реагують на повітряній
тривоги от доходить до вас якась
інформація як це відбувається на місцях
для того щоб
свідомо і автоматично навіть реагувати
на повітряний темоги в школах до цього в
серпні місяці було проведено більше ніж
36 тисяч гривень тренування з
працівниками ідей снс батьки збиралися
батьківські збори збиралися діяти з 1
вересня обов'язково є вимогою є
проведення тренувань щодо
реакції на
сигнал повітряної тривоги в будь-якому
випадку Кожна дитина має спуститись
кожен вчитель має прослідкувати щоб
дитина спустилася в Google обов'язково
щоб обов'язково ще в атестованих школах
обладнані wi-fi обладнання стільчиками
стільчиками проекторами ми до речі
проінспектували декілька шкіл наприклад
я щотижний інспектує але на 1 вересня в
мене було три перспективні поїздки
навіть не інспективних а таких
ознайомчих поїздів до школи
де діти діти мають можливість
зосередитись не просто на
схованці від ракетного удару А ще і
зосередитись над тим що буде проводиться
певні заняття
залишати колбосховище до
дебілів
неможливо тому в сховищах є і водичка
питна технічна є туалети є стаціонарний
телефон є можливість займатись є
можливість для дошкільнят відпочивати є
можливість активні ігри є можливість
навіть до творчості тому в будь-якому
випадку держава Україна на виклик
російської агресії відповіла достойно ми
гідно розпочали освітній процес під час
війни і не збираємось його зупиняти адже
освіта - це парламент то просто з ваших
слів звучить так щоб бомбосховище ледь
не таке місце де можна весь день
провести а наскільки справді це коли ви
їздите в своїй інспекційні поїздки
наскільки відповідає дійсності його те
що ви розказуєте тому що ну показувати
можна все Але чи справді є у всіх школах
обладнане бомбосховище з вайфаєм з
екранами з місцями відпочинку і дозвілля
для дошкільнят чи там молодших класів
яким треба відпочивати це величезні
площі які мають бути захищені це
підвальні приміщення які мають бути
обладнані чи справді вони всюди де про
це прозвітовано відповідають оцим
високим вимогам про які ви кажете
Дуже гарне запитання для нас сьогодні
акцентом є не просто наявність сходу
наявність бомбосховища або укриття на
сьогодні є Довіра батьків адже ми
запустили певний флешмоб Повертайся до
навчання і ми завжди на зв'язку з
батьківською спільнотою найбільше
батьківська спільнота в Україні це
батьки SOS
в цьому контексті ми завжди реагуємо
навіть до жодної школи до жодної громади
в якій відбувається певні певні там ну
якби непорозуміння і ми завжди виходимо
на зв'язок на сьогодні хочу сказати
64% шкіл обладнані достойними укриттям
такого точно немає в більшості країн
світу
адже на сьогодні Україна потерпає від
навалу російської агресії і Ми вимушені
заради майбутнього реагувати на жорстку
на систему таку задачу поставив
президент і таку задачу виконує уряд
разом з головами bca з керівниками
громад і з усіма освітянами
Зрозуміло дякую Тепер про тих
українських учнів які зараз перебувають
за кордоном мені доводилося бачити цифру
єврокомісії про те що 506 тисяч
українських дітей шкільного віку зараз
перебувають в ЄС і вони теж там пішли до
школи але хоча ми орієнтуємося дуже
часто на якісь європейські і
середньозважений рівень освіти є
предмети які в європейських школах не
викладають наприклад українська мова або
Історія України як ці діти будуть
підтримувати впродовж навчального року
оці особливі українські предмети
над актуальне питання дуже дякую Що ви
його задали як завжди фахова як
журналіст ви чітко виокремлюєте ті
питання які сьогодні більше за всіх
турбують суспільство присутність Це була
цифра десь на
22-25
серпня Але при цьому європейці
обліковували лише тих дітей які пішли до
них до школи які записались і в
обліковується в освітньому процесі в
березні місяці дітей шкільного віку які
виїхали в країни Європи у нас було 670
тисяч на сьогодні ми маємо на сьогодні
дітей які залишилися поза межами митної
території України ми маємо 492 077 людей
і я маю стриманий оптимізм оскільки
більше ніж 170 тисяч вже поверх дітей
шкільного віку вже повернулися в Україну
А на сьогодні в нас
навіть на в першій в перші дні війни це
мабуть 25 було лютого Коли я мав знизу з
усіма міністрами країни Європейського
Союзу де просив перш за все діти
виїжджають до вас я просив влаштувати їх
в школу для того щоб вони не відставали
освітнього процесу але при цьому
забезпечити певні формальні не формальні
і дуже суворий стандарти українського
освітнього нарадиву щодо історії України
українською мовою історія культури
України Це мало бути від 3 до 5 годин на
тиждень або Суботня школа для наших
маленьких українців в українських
шкільного віку який ви долучали до шкіл
з при цьому використовуючи
наших викладачів які перебувають в тій
чи іншій країні з тим щоб діти не
забували про Україну не забували про
українську культуру не забували про
українську мову І готові були
повернутися до України з новими силами
щодо відновлення її після навалом
російської агресії
зрозуміло Це зі школярами тепер хотілося
поцікавитися А як зі студентами
Наскільки я розумію Зараз якраз
відбувається зарахування на державну
форму навчання студентів чи є якась
статистика скільки людей вступило на
бюджетну форму навчання і Які
спеціальності можливо найцікавіші були
для абітурієнтів дякую дякую вам знов
таки за влучне і дуже-дуже такі
актуальне питання адже цей рік по вступу
був надзвичайно важливий для нас як для
самоствердження України в сфері вищої
освіти в цій частині зовсім змінився
зовсім змінився механізм і народив
вступу ви організували національний
мультиплектний тест які могли здавати
діти не тільки в межах території України
а ще в 40 містах країн 32 українців
світу в нас тільки на сьогодні здавав
209 тисяч
випускників ще не Ми ще не дійшли до
спеціальної сесії але при цьому на
сьогодні ми маємо 209 тисяч 200
24 тисяч випускників 11-х класів які вже
здали національними прикметниками з них
22 тисячі дітей наших абітурієнтів здало
їх за кордоном на сьогодні станом на 10
годину
5 вересня ми маємо 58 тисяч вже
вступників які на основі першої
загальної середньої освіти повної
загальної середньої освіти вже вступили
до закладів вищої освіти з них 144
170 ой вибачте 44 173 особи вступили на
бюджет і 13
837 осіб вступило на контракт далі буде
І ми щиро сподіваємось щиро віримо що
наші діти довіряють українській освіті А
скільки з цих студентів які вступили з
тимчасово окупованих територій є така
статистика
безмежно Дякую за ці актуальні питання
оскільки на сьогодні держава Україна в
особі президента особі уряду в особі
міністра з
реінтеграції на сьогодні ми дуже
опікувались тим щоби повернути всіх
наших дітей і ні в якому разі не дати
можливості
країні-агресору насаджувати свої
російські народи сьогодні по квоті два
вступило рекорд на кількість за всі 8
років взагалі існування російської
агресії до України
13665 осіб з них на бюджет
129509 це не означає те що комусь не
дали право вступити на бюджет є діти які
свідомо вступали на контракт але по
квоті два люди з тимчасово окупованих
територій діти діти які
всіх територій вступають виключно без
ЗНО на основі
індивідуальної онлайн або усною
співбесіди і вступають виключно за кошти
державного бюджету України тож Дякую
пане Сергію що знайшли час відповісти на
всі ці питання тому що справді вони для
людей особливо для абітурієнтів школярів
і їхніх батьків більш ніж актуальні
Сергій шкарлет Міністр освіти і науки
України був з нами в Ефі